hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game that just finished from
round two of this year's Norway chess we
are in the classical section and it is
Ariana versus the game that I mentioned
that uh finished uh while I was
recording the previous video and it's uh
it's as the title says a blunder uh
basically wins the game how this is
possible uh with such elite players well
that's just empty anything that can
happen also will happen uh and uh you
know of course it happens everywhere in
life but here it's it's very rare to see
with such a skilled elite players so
let's see what I mean by this uh let's
check it out the audientari has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have Pawn to C5 uh another way goes for
the Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 Knight
the C6 and Bishop to B5 challenging the
ceiling with the Nish meddino the
rosolimo attack Ponte D6 and Castle so
now this is all very standard stuff
Bishop to D7 Rook D1 Knight to F6 and
pawn to H3 we have upon the A6
challenging the light Square Bishop
Bishop back all the way to F1 and now
there are many uh popular moves that can
be played here like E5 E6 G6 even in G5
if you want to be super aggressive but
the move that another big plays is a
move that has never been played before
and that is Rook to G8 simply preparing
Pawn to G5 and it is now as of move 7
that we have a completely new game and
for a classical game that features a
Sicilian Defense uh that is not
something that we see often but you know
as as we go further into the future it's
something that we are getting used to
more and more as players are really
going out of their way to try and
surprise the other guy as much as
possible so D3 uh Pawn to H6 preparing
G5 and now Irene says all right I can't
just uh you know wait be idle and wait
for a G5 G4 I have to create something
and he plays Pawn to B4 and uh this is
not recommended by the engine but once
you play the engine says all right I was
wrong this is actually perfectly fine as
it often is with with moves like Pawn to
B4 and now how do you react to this so
of course if you capture with the Knight
then you lose control over the E5 Square
let's say Knight captures E5 and now
after d captures Knight captures your
king is still in the center of the board
and since you want to attack on the king
side you want to keep the center close
it's a general principle in chess so C
captures mb4 instead and now Pawn to A3
trying to give up more material to it at
the develop pieces and start an attack
against the black king so upon the B3
attacking the base of the pawn chain and
now just Pawn to see for not willing to
to capture away from the center and pawn
to G5 and okay uh Queen capture some B3
Pawn to G4 another box attack is uh
progressing very nicely H captors Knight
captures and now Pawn to D4 you can see
that it's not very easy to Checkmate the
white king as long as this Knight is an
F3 so Quinta A5 and now Knights the C3
just nicely developing uh the point is
okay if you try something like Queen to
H5 sure you can try that but
uh there's just no way to kick this
Knight away from F3 you could consider
some like Knight captures on the
fortnite captures and then Queen to H2
Checkmate but Bishop to F4 stops all of
that so now you will have to wait with
checkmating idea so just Bishop to G7
continuing development with Tempo the D4
Pawn is now hanging and pawn to E5 with
it D captures an E5 and now a nice
solution to uh Bishop to D2 making e
captures and D for impossible because if
you do this then just Knights the D5
opening up an attack against the queen
and there's no good way to react to this
if Queen back to d8 you will play Bishop
to F4 and now you are really in in
trouble Knight the C7 check is happening
the E7 Pawn is under a lot of pressure
so you don't want to play this yeah so
instead after Bishop to D2 uh another
way just goes back with the queen queen
38 and now Pawn to D5 attacking the
Knight here Knight to D4 and not Knight
captures on D4 now it's a little bit
different because the queen has no
access to H4 so uh e cap percent D4 and
not Knight to E4 and here we have Bishop
D5 Knights the D6 check is kind of a
threat but as you'll see not really a a
great one Bishop to A5 now with some
ideas of Bishop to H do check if if
needed Pawn the F4 and now Bishop back
to h8 and remarkable as it is Knight the
D6 check doesn't do anything for white
it will just move the king and if
anything even black is better here there
is not uh another good way to counter
this uh once the pawn moves the queen is
coming to H4 it's not going to be pretty
so after Bishop they trade just Pawn to
C5 now you are ready to start advancing
some pawns here King the f8 sidestepping
this check because it might be useful in
the future and now Rook a to C1 now
really preparing Pawn to C5 Pawn to D3 a
beautiful move by nod Rebecca point
being that after Queen captures on D3 uh
you have Bishop to B5 and now where is
the queen going you can't go to C3 you
can't go to E3 you have to move from D3
and once you move Bishop to D4 check and
you have all all sorts of new problems
here there's no good way to get out of
this so instead Bishop to C3 you have to
counter this monster Bishop on h8 uh
Pawn to E6 and now just um uh Pawn to C6
going after the bishop on D7 so upon the
C6 and now Bishop captures and C3 you
could consider some other moves but
um uh you know it's not an not easy B
captures on C6 kind of should be played
but it's uh it's very hard to to play to
play a move like this so Bishop captures
on C3 Queen captures on C3 and now comes
Queen to H4
and this is what I meant by the title of
the video uh it's exactly this blunder
that wins Notre back the game Queen to
H4 seems like a scary move because Queen
to H2 will be Checkmate uh but uh feel
free to pause the video and figure out
why this is actually losing the game uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that uh
well uh that uh that previous line that
we've discussed B captures and C6 the
reason why I didn't show it to you is
because it would spoil the pause the
video moment it kind of involves the
same tactic so if you if you found that
then truly congratulations and for those
of you who just won't enjoy the show it
is Queen to B4 with check which is
different than what um was played in the
game tari played Queen to C5 check and
that does not work the point is that
after Queen to B4 check how do you react
if King to E8 you just get to checkmated
okay that's pretty straightforward
you're gonna capture King date you're
gonna play a check here King captures
Rook to C7 check and as the king hunt
progresses you will very quickly get
checkmated King f8 and Rook captures on
F7 will be Checkmate so the point is
after Queen the B for check you have to
go to G7 but now what's the problem with
uh White's position well you're getting
checkmated on H2 so let's just cover the
H2 Square Queen to B2 with check also
covers the H2 Square King goes to f8 and
now Pawn to G3 opens up the way for the
White Queen and also with Tempo because
the black queen is now attacked which
means you're just going to lose the
bishop for free Queen will have to move
you're gonna capture on D7 and that's
pretty much it you capture an E6 as well
whatever Queen captures Bishop captures
and D3 you're up a full Bishop you are
winning this game easily and black has
no real uh real threats here so that's
the problem however Queen to C5 check
was played and now another Big's attack
is coming with Tempo King the G7 Bishop
captures on D3 and now Queen to H do
with check and the King hunt begins King
F1 Queen captures an F4 with check King
to E2 and now e captures on D5 making
Queen captures on D5 impossible because
if you go for this then Queen to eth
Richard King D1 and now Bishop captures
on C6 there's just no good way to handle
this Bishop T for check coming next and
if you don't do anything well
uh the the queen is hanging also you
can't capture the queen if you capture
the queen then just Knight captures it
with E3 with check we also will pick up
the queen so it's just gonna be up too
much material uh no point in doing that
so the move you have to play here is
actually Queen to D4 check but the disc
was missed by tari point is that now uh
okay obviously you can trade Queens but
uh why would another do that for example
uh F6 you're gonna capture on D7 D
captures any for Queen captures and now
you really have no other move than to
trade Queens as the White Queen will
infiltrate Black's position and after
captures and captures uh White has
enough uh to hold this to a draw however
in the game rooked F1 was played by tari
and now comes uh a very nice Queen to E5
covering that D4 Square C captures on D7
and Rook a to d8 eliminating all Contra
play from uh from tari Queen to C3
offering a queen trade and not just the
captors on e4 and trading Queens isn't
all that spectacular if you trade Queens
right away Bishop captures an E4 Rook
captures on D7 it's only black was
pushing for a win here so instead after
d captures an E4 we have Bishop captures
on e4 Rook campus on D7 and now Rook the
F4 of course and that cannot be captured
as the the queen is pinned to the king
so Queen captures on C3 Rook captures on
C3 and Knight to E5 now we have Rook to
G3 with Chuck uh Knight to G6 and even
Rook after G4 and although it seems like
it's white who's attacking uh there's no
danger here it's only
um another back who is up two full Pawn
so Rook the E8 pins the bishop King to
F2 and now comes Rook to E6 and here a
much cleaner way to win with spawn to H5
uh now the The Rook really doesn't have
uh all that many squares okay we can
play Rook 4 because the Knight is pinned
but still let's say Rook to D2 with
check King to G1 now King the H6 and
your Rook is hanging and if something
like Bishop captures and G6 you will
play Rook to E1 with checking to H2 and
now Rook the D1 going after Rook to H1
Checkmate and after you stop this with
something like Rook to D3 you will
happily trade F captures and G6 row
captures Road captures and you are up to
full Pawns of course you will win this
game uh but instead Rook the E6 was
played uh kind of adding another
Defender to the G6 knight uh Bishop to
D3 and now Pawn to A5 just putting
pieces and pawns on optimal Square spawn
to A4 upon to B6 King to G1 and now Rook
the D5 winning more space Bishop to C4
um obscuring the Rooks but it doesn't
really matter Rook to D1 with Chuck King
to H2 and now just to Rook e to E1 going
for Rook to H1 Checkmate here we have
Rook to F3 uh giving the king the G3
square but now look at this beauty Pawn
to H5 and now how do you react to this
uh Rook the G5 was played the problem is
if Rook captures an F7 which seems like
a beautiful move uh there's King to H6
and look at this look at the the horror
of of this position the the white Rook
has no squares you can't go here you
can't go here you can't go here uh you
can't go anywhere if you go here then
you block the G3 square root H1 will
again be Checkmate you can go here due
to the Knight so you're only a option is
root captures King captures but now
you're also Down The Exchange while
being down upon so of course completely
winning for black instead after H5 Rook
the G5 was played but here just Pawn to
H4 and it was in this position on move
46 that aryantari resigned the game and
another brilliant victory for another
satrov in this year's round two of uh of
Norway chess so he takes the full point
uh he wins in classical which means that
he gets three points he doesn't have to
go into Armageddon here the G3 square is
covered a rook to H1 will be Checkmate
and the only way to defend this is not
pretty let's say Pawn to G3 Rook to H1
with check will lose you even more
material let's say Pawn to H3 creates a
pass pawn and now if King to F2 now
Ponte F sorry I want the F6 will
challenge The Rook here and once The
Rook moves a rook to H2 with check
forces the king away from the first and
second rank King to E3 and now you just
move the Rook from the H2 square and now
the pawn is becoming a queen uh and even
even some silly Contra player like
Bishop to D3 okay looks like you might
have something here not really just Rook
D1 with check the King has to go up the
board and whatever you play with the
King D4 Rook the B4 with check and you
will pick up the rook and G4 now for
only only one of the lines but pretty
much um yeah everything ends the same
for white uh so yeah a beautiful win in
the classical section uh by not Rebecca
lusatrov in round two of this year's
Norway chess uh we're cut we're gonna
cover more games from round two as it's
really a bloodbath you know a complete
Massacre all of the games are on fire
and we're gonna discuss the standings
only after I have covered a sufficient
number of games uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh so you
can see it's not even in bullet and
Blitz or even rapid that you can win
games by completely blundering the game
it is also in classical so Queen to H4
completely blunders but uh you know if
if both players miss it then it's
completely fine uh I I wonder at what
point another exported it because it
would be team you know if he spotted it
as soon as he played it maybe Tai would
pick up on it is it's very hard to
imagine that he could remain calm but
maybe he didn't see it for the rest of
the game and then you know maybe a
casual uh you know uh
person watching you know just told him
hey you know that Queen H4 was a
complete blunder and then they would be
amazed so who knows what happened uh but
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by another
Beck
um uh I would like to thank Marcus
gravel Bunty revision reptiles YouTube
Michael zacarius and David esparian for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this uh wonderful event until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day